[Música]
[Aplausos]
existe uma frase que eu uso
sistematicamente quadro de rotina que
diz não existe não consigo também essa
frase pode não ser das mais simpáticas
ou muito menos mais modestas mas sei que
eu poderia fazer eu sou um dos filhos da
geração y
as primeiras levadas o que significa que
os meus pais eram extremamente dedicados
extremamente trabalhadores extremamente
amorosos e me amaram demais alimentaram
demais e protegeram demais
de fato isso na minha casa não podia ser
mais verdade eu cresci ouvindo isso e
acreditando que tudo o que eu quisesse
poderia alcançar tudo que eu lutasse
para fazer eu poderia chegar a alcançar
não existe não consigo ver um chavão pra
mim talvez por uma certa prepotência
talvez por falta de experiência ou
simplesmente porque eu vivi ouvindo isso
passando quase 30 anos para o dia 15 de
março de 2015
eu era já um jovem médico terminou no
mestrado professor de ortopedia uma das
faculdades mais prestigiados do país
eu tinha alcançado profissionalmente
aquilo que eu tinha desejado
eu era casado com uma mulher maravilhosa
pai de um filho lindo e nós estávamos
esperando nosso segundo filho ainda na
barriga de uma casa linda eu tinha um
cachorro
eu tinha um quintal linda eu tinha
conseguido tudo profissionalmente e
pessoalmente que eu tinha desejado
naquele dia nesse dia 15 de março de
2015 nós resolvemos comemorar o
aniversário da minha mãe da minha casa
eu tinha passado o dia inteiro fazendo
churrasco pra família cozinhando para
todo mundo enquanto observava o pessoal
como eu adoro fazer um churrasco fazer
comida enquanto várias pessoas comerem
lá pelas tantas a minha irmã mais nova
se aproximou de mim e quando vai
conversando com meu pai e falou vamos
dar um mergulho na piscina
eu não estava muito disposto e depois de
uma certa insistência eu resolver todo
há a idéia de mergulhar saí correndo e
meu pai na frente e ela acompanhou a
gente logo atrás
até que na hora de mergulhar na piscina
um dos meus cachorros ocorreu na minha
frente e entrou no caminho
podia ter chutado ele entrando com ele
não dá água
eu podia ter parado mas resolveu saltar
por cima dele tendo aí um salto
totalmente desajeitada e batendo com a
cabeça no fundo da piscina
na hora que eu bati com a cabeça no
fundo da piscina eu senti
automaticamente um choque no meu corpo
inteiro começa no pescoço e na
extremidade de todo o meu corpo parecia
que eu tinha sido atingido por um trovão
todos os meus neurônios periféricos
disparavam ao mesmo tempo e por um
ortopedista é uma experiência única
poder vivenciar o que uma lesão medular
faz no seu próprio corpo
naquele momento era extremamente curioso
saber como aquilo acontecesse eu estava
deslumbrado
só tem um detalhe estava embaixo d'água
eu precisava respirar ainda comecei a
fazer um esforço hercúleo para poder
nadar até a superfície e um esforço
ainda maior para me manter na superfície
quando vi meu pai nadando do meu lado
que tinha mergulhado com sucesso graças
a deus veio pra ele e falei
tranquilamente pai me ajuda aqui que deu
merda pra mim ter uma resposta ainda
mais curiosa da merda não obviamente eu
troquei de um merda assim não era bem o
momento de ficar filosofando sobre o
assunto e ele viu o desespero na minha
cara
com mais de 30 anos de médico socorrista
trabalhando emergência ele foi passou
braço por baixo da mesa axilas e levou
até a borda da piscina
nesse curso trajeto de mais ou menos uns
dois três metros
o pietro racional professor portou
petista já tinha sumido completamente a
situação eu passei nesse trajeto
testando dras esquerdo mão esquerda
funcionando
braço-direito funcionando em mão direita
morta
nada do tronco para baixo funcionava era
no mínimo curioso a sensação de mandar o
estímulo e nada acontecia
a minha mãe se aproximou
desesperadamente falando tirando a água
tinha barba tira de dentro d'água
mas nessa hora já estava em outra
dimensão que é a primeira resposta que
eu tive foi só você daqui de colar
cervical prancha longa explicada pode
chamar o bombeiro faz favor ligar para o
meu orientador do mestrado e avisa para
ele que eu não vou poder que eu tive um
probleminha bom
a sensação ea descoberta principalmente
da anestesia de passar a mão em uma
parte do corpo e não sentir uma
anestesia que não terminava foi deixando
de ser algo curioso virando algo
assustador até ver algo desesperador
eu tinha começado o dia tendo tudo que
eu queria que naquele momento não tinha
nem mais a mim mesmo eu fui operado
naquela madrugada
e nessas situações extremas
impressionante como algumas coisas se
revelam
eu posso falar tranquilamente que em
nenhum momento tive medo da morte e isso
numa forma desapegada de demonstrar
coragem uma coragem o brasil um
sentimento bairrista de casa não tenho
medo da morte
não eu realmente tinha um instinto de
autopreservação muito prejudicado era
meio kamikaze tanto por negligência por
imprudência o período por imperícia mas
não vou continuar falando muito isso
aqui vocês vão achar que eu sou maluco
o fato é que a primeira vez que eu
realmente comecei a me preocupar de
verdade que a minha integridade física
foi depois que eu conhecia a minha
esposa mas naquela noite eu tive medo
eu tive muito medo tanto é que eu virei
para um colega meu anestesista e pedi
pra ele favor cara fica na sala comigo
não sei se ele poderia influenciar
alguma coisa mas eu sabia que eu
precisava desesperadamente de ajuda
tanto é que um pouco antes dia realmente
a pagar neste dizia eu venho para o meu
pai falei confidência
por favor se não acordar ajuda a tomar
conta dos meus filhos enfim cara que eu
acordei obviamente
e eu estava bastante prejudicado estava
seriamente danificado
eu estava usando fralda eu não consegui
me virar na cama se tirar seis barras
laterais da cana
eu tinha dificuldade de respirar fundo
mas a cabeça continua funcionando
perfeitamente tanto é que eu me lembro
que alguém virou pra mim falou
deixa eu tirar uma foto sua para mandar
para sua esposa que tinha ficado em casa
rezando não estava me acompanhando o sol
naquele momento e eu instintivamente
levantei a mão direita que a minha
dominante com toda força do mundo que eu
conseguia em sinal de ok para mandar pra
ela assim estou vivo também vai dar tudo
certo
no dia seguinte quando eu acordei de
tarde há só uma coisa existia na minha
cabeça minha esposa está grávida de
quatro meses
eu tenho cinco meses pra ficar em pé
a partir daí a idéia é não existe não
consigo então vamos lá vamos provar que
não existe não conseguirá provar que não
existe não consigo eu comecei a engolir
fisioterapia duas vezes por dia três
vezes por dia quantas vezes a equipe
passasse um quarto para me ver
cada movimento solicitado era feito com
intensidade máxima mesmo que para
levantar um pé eu fizesse uma força
parecia que eu estava levantando uma
montanha a cada frustração única forma
de recuperar o ânimo era lembrando todas
as pessoas parentes amigos e amores que
estavam ali sofrendo comigo eu tinha
muita vontade de chorar mas eu tentava
sorri o tempo inteiro pra não piorar o
sofrimento
bom se as pernas não funcionavam com 23
do hospital ainda internado eu resolvi
ir que é o momento de começar a
fortalecer os braços e comecei a fazer
musculação assim que a minha mão direita
começou a a conseguir segurar alguma
coisa
ainda deitado na maca do hospital
de acordo com a equipe a minha chance de
recuperação que estava em torno de 20%
a meta da minha equipe de fisioterapia é
que eu consegui sentar por volta de três
meses com o auxílio mas com algumas
semanas eu já estava conseguindo me
levantar para sentar com a ajuda de
sentado num em pé
o prognóstico era de que menos de 50%
das pessoas com casos como o meu andar
sem de novo com o auxílio e em seis
meses
então essa era outra meta a ser batida
finalmente eu fui pra casa e quando
cheguei em casa o cenário que eu me
deparei foi o que os americanos costumam
chamar de uma instituição não tinha como
não vencer
toda a seqüência de eventos que
aconteceu da hora do acidente
ao final da minha reabilitação foi
considerada em uma seqüência de eventos
muita sorte ou milagre para aquelas
pessoas que acreditam em milagre eu fui
socorrido pelo melhor socorrista
alterado para o melhor cirurgião
reabilitado pela melhor equipe de
fisioterapia cuidado e amparada pelos
amigos mais fiéis e movido pela nova
força que o ser humano pode ter
o amor bom isso me levou aqui na hora
que eu tinha que chegar no momento
definitivo eu conseguir cumprir a meta o
objetivo que eu tinha que era de receber
o meu filho em pé
isso me fez refletir muita coisa e me
colocou de frente para a seguinte
situação eu particularmente nunca fui
muito bom em conseguir nada sozinho
já falei tantas vezes na vida em tantas
coisas que se for para pensar todas as
vitórias e conquistas digna de nota que
eu tive foram por alguém com alguém ou
em alguém sozinho ou não existe não
consigo é quase uma piada
já falei tantas vezes que não vale a
pena nem
iraque e isso me fez pensar por que que
eu sou assim porque a maioria dos seres
humanos é assim porque nós somos assim
porque o homem um animal tão social é
assim por que vocês vieram aqui por
exemplo ouvia idéias que vale a pena
compartilhar se der não são fatos e
idéias são percepções que vocês estão
tendo do interlocutor totalmente em vias
largas por quem está falando
a explicação que eu consigo dar pra
vocês como cientista é que isso vem da
nossa própria natureza do nosso próprio
código genético
nós somos um aglomerado de moléculas
praticamente idêntico com uma
modificação genética extremamente
parecida que tem na sua programação
gastar vida pra gerar vida não
necessariamente na forma de procriação
mas a cada vez que você influencia um
próximo na hora que você toca na hora
que você inspira na hora que você
transfere e faz sorrir
você está gerando vida a primeira vez
que você teve contato com esse mundo
você já era a pessoa mais importante na
vida de alguém e esta pessoa já era a
pessoa mais importante na sua vida você
aprendeu desde cedo que seu principal
referencial na vida não era uma coisa
era uma pessoa
a primeira vez que você se alimentou
você se encheu de alguém que
literalmente estava se esvaziado por
você
todas as vezes que você pensa um
sentimento forte qual o sentimento mais
forte que vem à cabeça
a maioria das pessoas vai responder o
amor é uma paixão aguda é tão forte é
capaz de encharcar as suas conexões
nervosas sinais de tal forma que o
próprio possam dizer que o amor é uma
forma grave de doença mental e lhe
perturba todas as suas conexões e tira o
seu referencial
existe alguma dor maior do que perder
alguém esse ano
nenhum objeto por mais
por mais raro que exista é capaz de
preencher essa falha que preenchesse
buraco
instintivamente nós buscamos inspiração
em pessoas porque nós sabemos no fundo
nosso circo que apenas uma vida é capaz
de inspirar uma vida
a ideia que eu tenho que vale a pena
compartilhar na verdade não é bem uma
ideia é uma visão que eu tive
diante dessa situação toda às vezes nós
nos sentimos sozinhos nós nos sentimos
perdidos nós nos sentimos muito distante
do objetivo e as coisas podem aparecer
longe demais para ser alcançada distante
de mais difíceis demais pra mim ficar em
pé
era assim longe de mais difícil de mais
distante e max efetivamente aquilo era
difícil demais pra mim eu percebi que
seria difícil demais pra você você pode
fazer por alguém fazendo e se ficar uma
coisa muito mais fácil muito mais
acessível
não existe não consigo nunca funcionou
muito bem para mim até hoje não funciona
direito
mas eu hoje tenho certeza absoluta de
que não existe
não conseguimos ninguém está sozinho
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]